une impression d'icônes rendu par un
contraste clair obscur appuyer un
travail de la lumière à la manière des
peintres espagnol du xviie siècle
des clichés de plain pied près dans
l'intimité pour rendre compte de huit
portraits huit parcours de vie issue du
métissage culturel
ce sont les étranges étrangères de
barbara pèlerins la photo de plain pied
c'est l'occasion de
de faire du portrait afin de faire un
portrait un peu complet vient de là de
la tête aux pieds en prenant en compte
le vêtement la façon dont les femmes
sont habillées les pieds qui sont assez
présents dans la composition les objets
qui souvent sont posés sur le sol c'est
un cadrage qui est un véritable parti
pris à la fois parce que c'est un rappel
à la pluralité et et en même temps parce
que l'identité c'est pas simplement le
visage un travail manifeste de la
richesse de la diversité culturelle
auquel est attaché barbara pèlerins
artiste engagé l'ancien élève de l'école
boulle et de l'école nationale de la
photographie à arles prolonge ses
recherches dans ses ateliers du bel air
à montreuil sur le thème de la
binationalité une passion qu'elle
partage également avec ses élèves du
conservatoire des arts de montigny le
bretonneux
ce qui me plaît c'est que c'est
l'histoire l'histoire de chaque femme
du coup qui devient un patrimoine parce
que ces femmes vivent pour la plupart du
temps depuis longtemps en france elles
ont eu des enfants en france et elles
ont une histoire qui est passionnante
parce que justement il ya eu le voyage
pourquoi elles ont quitté leur pays
d'origine l'arrivée en france et
comment on
on se considère à la fois française et
en même temps d'un pays étranger
l'exposition étrange étrangères a été
commandée par la ville de guyancourt
dans le cadre de la journée de la femme
elle est présentée à la mezzanine de
l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt jusqu'au
19 mars avec un vernissage prévu le 10
mars prochain